[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kissin
and this is the show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our fantastic expert guest this week is
Toni sole who's the founder of
generating genius which is a charity
that helps inner-city kids get to top
universities here in the UK Tony welcome
to trigonometry thanks for having me
[Music]
it's so good to have here here the
question we always like to ask at the
beginning is how are you where you are
what's been your journey through life
well I suppose I mean my journey is an
interesting one because it's um I think
it sort of defines really for me what
what's happening now and then I look
back at that past and see it kind of a
line going in I think the line was
always how do I kind of disrupt what is
given for me so for example I was given
a crap school
yeah crap secondary school where all of
us were expected well what happened was
quite interesting that the white kids in
the school went and got jobs usually
with their uncles or whatever or friends
and there those connections and it seems
to me that's quite interesting how they
got work the black boys in this school
well we had a hard harder time I mean a
lot of us were unemployed but and really
the way out for us this is a boys school
was was hard I would admit that this was
back in in the 70s yeah and I think that
I think for me the route then became
almost how do i how do I now kind of
redefine myself in this in this
interesting situation where nothing was
really happening I remember I used to
bunk off school basically to go to the
library try to get some things but my
mother was quite smart on this one so
what she did was she and there was three
of us my brother and my sister she
packed us off quite early too and
Anglicans and can church you know it
wasn't high Anglican no one and it was I
mean angry Church of England and and in
a very middle-class scene all-white City
and so he just went in there and we were
we were the token black kids in that in
that church but there were really nice
people and they you know they we did
nice things but what was interesting was
that it changed our perception because
suddenly
you had a I think for it for I always
look at this for anybody as a sort of
adolescent growing up your peer groups
gonna define a lot of who you are and
how you work you know that and and so
and I says we were subtly given this new
peer group of middle-class kids and they
went off to university and they came
back in in the summer and so ok they
were armed they were our new friends and
so that's what you do now cuz in our
schools nobody went to university but
for us that that was a changes all right
I want to be like my friends so I better
go after university so we we will tell
you about how we're gonna do this
because these grad schools how we gonna
get there and and so we just I suppose
but it's quite interesting that that
didn't seem to be that difficult and I
and say that because if you're it's so
some of this stuff is about motivation
is about that drive in to do something
is there obviously you do need to have
some of the stuff in place but to be
socially mobile a lot of it and that
that's why I began to think about social
mobility that a lot of it was quite
intrinsic yeah and so therefore that set
us off on that journey or me on that
journey to sort of go off the university
and and and I think ever since then I've
always had the tension between almost
like middle class people trying to sort
of work out what I am and who I am and
and and and and that kind of desire to
do something different so for example if
you I remember going to III I'm also
defined by my Jamaican background as
well when my parents was in Jamaica and
I and then and all of that was very
important in the 70s for us and and but
it wasn't the sole sole thing that
defined me you know I had another part
of me which was I don't know just
another part of me I like I love
classical music for example I love bark
and things like that and I remember
going to the south bank and the I don't
remember this band called Osibisa that I
remember
there was an African band they were
playing on one corner and then they were
in the Purcell rooms but was playing
another I got my ticket to go to the
first room and I remember the gun the
guy at the door actually blocking me
from the BART concert saying that you
got girls to do this because that's one
of black people yeah you say that but he
just said what we in there you know
because what it might have been
something was gonna harm me if I was
gonna because I was gonna video I was
about 17 and the someone was gonna
someone was gonna harm me if I was gonna
go in there listen to Barnea
I'm gonna go jump up with all the other
black people OSI visa that's really good
and if you like that kind of thing was
continually kind of you go in you go in
as um this is just one of the reason why
I'm adamant about this is I had a recent
interview with The Sunday Times yeah
which I I don't know slam the journalist
but I'm it was a good interview now we
have some offices in central London it
just happened that way PA
she booked her office which was I mean
it was a very small room yeah and it was
and she brought her intern in there so
it was three of us in the room and we
were talking and I was relaxed as you
can see I've got a South London accent i
i'm i'm hopefully I'm fairly articulate
with you I'm comfortable with my accent
I love my South London background anyway
when I read the piece after we had
Dudley's of her thing was I'm 6 foot 2
I'm a mess of me I don't think I'm I
don't know if I'm that kind of
intimidating anyway her first comment
was well in this cramped room with Tony
who has a massive frame and a raspberry
Croydon accent you know
and that was the first definition of so
I was kind of wondering and reminds me
of the scene and you see a Mel Brooks's
Blazing Saddles the seed is there if
there's a black sheriff who comes into
town he's very good at sort of usurping
things and the sheriff comes in to they
haven't they've killed the existing
sheriff so new one comes he but this is
sort of like in the backwoods of Western
and of course the new sheriff is a black
guy coming in town and so he gets up
with the stage and starts addressing the
audience and then puts his hand just
slightly down to where his Dickies and
then suddenly all the women go as if
something terrible's gonna happen
that kind of scene reminded me of that
because I said what was wrong before
I've been and then of course all my
friends and it's quite interesting they
missed the article and they just went
straight for that just say well Tony
what was wrong with this woman I wrote
to her and I said to her look you know I
didn't really I didn't understand you
detracted from the other bits in them
please by just saying that and she said
oh no no we have to always set a context
for our guests you know the other piece
in this case of context was that you're
black kind of working-class ting which I
think in class people get I I wore a
nice suit yeah in there cuz I wanted
that I want us to get a nice sharp shot
for us charity and I had some patent
shoes I thought they looked kind of
sharp I was wearing those as well and
then she pointed to he was wearing this
push suit and patent shoes it was like
you know it reminds me of the thing in
Only Fools and Horses where Rodney's
always you know the drinks thing he has
a flash drink as if working-class people
are trying to be here for [ __ ] mean that
kind of so it's kind of tonight that
that kind of a and that's the dual thing
you get and it's a very English thing
you know you on the other hand you're a
black man and it always current
they're always obsessed with your size
or whatever and on the other hand
there's this whole kind of
class thing about your accent and what
that tells you about your accent can
constantly obsess with it you know oh
which dust actually and I could be wrong
I don't see it happening a lot of other
countries I think that a very English
thing that we do with accents and I and
I can see people continually struggling
with that at times you know and even
those people who have made it you know
you can see them always referring back
to that kind of tension so that's that
was an interesting thing but they're not
you know who cares I did quite well got
CBE from Prince Charles he was alright
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's sort of part of the journey and
then um yeah well let's talk about
generating genius because you you've
talked about being stereotyped and what
you're just talking about there but
actually you're someone who who talks
extensively about the fact that in terms
of educational outcomes and things like
that it's not racism that prevents
people from advancing so it's a lack of
values or like a father's and them tell
us a little bit about yeah I mean the
thing is and it still is even though
that story because it's not done I'm
here to sort of crying about racism or
about worries me I actually think that
we we can talk about that we can go over
that but it you you have to you accept
the reality is that the society has
problems but it's not gonna hold you
back you know that's my mother's
attitude and that was what that was what
how we but what what I find is in the
balance of things I still would say that
what we what we do need is is is is this
sort of almost a kind of kind of sense
to tell young people that they've got
the age at the agency to actually kind
of get over this it's not it's not
insurmountable you should have to face
it but on the other hand it's it's and
it's certainly not as bad as it was in
the 70s and 80s
so there's actually progress in the
slide when one of one of the problems in
in all of this is that if you don't say
that then young people get locked in to
a world and they feel they can't get out
of it
hence the title generator ingenious
because if you if you go if you surround
poor people or people who are oppressed
with this sort of sense that they can do
yeah so generate engine see genius is
always kind of sense of it's out there
but you can just anybody can become a
genius Reid you have to put the things
together the opportunities and then you
can fly yeah so what I did is I I also
wanted to prove to myself that that that
formula was true and so what I did is I
I found the the group that was and that
was black boys who would who were
actually under achieving the worst in
that in in the society at the moment at
that time and it's improved to a certain
extent now in terms of school outcomes
and exclusions and I wanted to set them
a task too so right can you can I get a
group all the way through from the the
poorest backgrounds all the way through
to say Imperial College or Oxford
University and let's not do let's do not
doing easy stuff like weed in English
let's do some sciences yeah stuff that's
not associated with them okay right and
in a sense there is a sense and I say
this as profanes the society as well
that you know black boys really are not
that bright radium you can even hear it
from what some say not really that
bright
they basically best just doing a bit of
DJ and stuff like that but not they're
not really belonging the lab laboratory
discovering stuff you know so let's
let's find the hardest thing the thing
that isn't it was associated with them
and let's put them on that track and see
what happens so it was almost like a
laboratory experiment really for myself
and I found we started with 10 and then
we increased it to a hundred and there
were certain period quizzes around yes
they had to be bright yeah we knew that
and had to have it interested in science
but they had to were the first in their
family to University dirt poor
backgrounds and certainly none of their
school sent anybody
if more of their schools were sending
them to jail than University yeah so
that was that was the kind of setup we
had and I got them at 14 and then really
I just work with them and I'm looking
back now I look back at that hundred and
I would say the vast majority of them
narrow top universities they're in our
alumni if at last night we up I'll say
last night common I think we had a a
reception for those ones who came when
they were 14 now they're 24 yeah to the
Gulf and the program how it works is you
stay with us from 14 to the point that
you're at University and we work with
you in the out-of-school space in
holidays or excess just doing lots and
lots of sciences so it was like it was I
was like the Pied Piper I'd have this
group of black boys running around
Imperial College Cambridge now what I
did I used all my connections I had had
from my journey I just because I just
know a lot of people in that sense
because I just go everywhere and
everybody at that point wanted to help
so it was as if there was nothing really
stopping it happening you know all they
needed it was somebody in the middle to
facilitate it and I think that that's
the thinning them what's happening is
that it's not that nobody wants to do
anything for poor people nobody wants to
do anything from it's just that we can't
seem to connect we have a very difficult
way of doing this somehow stuffs over
here poor people are over here and no
one's in the middle doing the link it's
not as simple as that I know but it's
some of it is just about that yeah and
and and that that can be for a number of
reasons I think it's a lack of
understanding about what the
expectations that in fact what you can
do is you can put some so for example
some of the universities some of the
college's genuinely probably didn't
think that if you came from a poor part
of Brixton in the seventies eighties you
could get to understand so they don't go
for that well and then of course the
other worst thing is that those people
already in there don't think they can
get in there I ask worse really in some
ways that
so you have this equation of nobodies
like because nobody wants do they know
what again they don't think they can get
their [ __ ] and they don't want them to
come yeah yeah poverty of ambition yeah
yeah because it's not you said if you're
not surrounded by people who aspiring to
do that then why would you expire
together yeah and we've got a concept
called people like me which is really
good it's a simple kind of thing of
bringing the Alumni is quite powerful so
you can imagine our new cohort or little
kids now waiting and they can see that
look that of achieves once you once it
the cycle starts going it perpetuates
itself well it sounds like an amazing
thing that you're doing
from your Sunday Times piece what you're
talking about there is the fact that you
can't seem to get the politicians to
actually listen to what you're talking
about
I think we're where I've where I felt
where I've kind of not been able to
engage this is because I I've adamant
that I have not gone down the route of
saying it the fault of all this is
racism I think that's really been the
and they're people who are it means the
power has been chasing if I'd gone on
sides waving the flag and say all these
boys are oppressed because of systemic
racism I think I would probably get more
attention is that ironic Lee but I
haven't said that I've said that it is
this thing of the driver of ambition to
make it happen and yeah I I don't you
know honestly think that that is an
issue and I also think that there there
just are people who are just totally
hopeless who should be there in
positions of authority and power trying
to sort out the fact that working-class
people and not getting there right
forward you and then these are people
who run these agencies and I don't know
what they're doing and honestly I think
that that is okay I see it in terms of
universities I see in terms of charities
I see in terms of social agencies I
don't keep going around and I just see a
lot of people trying something but it
doesn't really it's not really working
and they want any scratch and in the end
it's almost like they say
it gets really bad this Oh your problems
are so complex that they can't be solved
ooh you know I mean I hit keep hearing
that oh the problem knife crap it's too
complicated there's too many things that
we don't we haven't got any solutions
the mayor says he's gonna take ten years
to solve it you see so in a sense the
the the solute the people who can come
to the solutions are just not at the
table and I just I don't know why that
is I mean maybe you just don't know you
buddy I don't know I mean but that's
been a problem for me and I and I and I
why I try and push myself and I'm not it
it's not me alone I'm thinking that I
know other people who should be in there
you know that place called the house of
laws for example where you've got people
who are strategically overviewing
laws and things like that but hardly any
of them sound or look like me in there
and also the answers they're not they're
not they're people who may have some of
the answers and they're not they're not
really getting it so in a way we've got
to try and completely redefine I think
with some accepting at the moment with
the Brixton where we're really
questioning and I like I like the
disruption of the other people say oh
this is it is horrible but what's going
on is I think people are waking up to
the fact that the so-called experts this
is it are not the experts and that's
that's really what's going on here they
don't know and they've managed to get in
their positions but mainly because of
who they know and I think that's that's
beginning to change now and I'd love to
see if I had a chance just people who do
know what they're doing in that position
and politically it would be different it
wouldn't necessarily be a liberal thing
it would be different people from
different backgrounds coming in and Rin
trying to sort this out so I think
that's that's where it's been stuck
[Music]
I mean you touched on in the article and
I remember reading that and I read the
article in the Sunday Times and I sort
of gasped when you know when you said it
because it's an issue that we touch with
tiptoe around I've taught in four
deprived schools in New London and a lot
of the children that do go on to join
gangs they don't have a father figure on
let me just tell you what's happened in
the unit in in the research sector in
the university in the discourses have
been happening in the people that hold
almost the power over over our knowledge
you that you would have thought that the
issue of boys would have been a case in
America another place they they have
they have looked at this issue in
England that the literature on this is
very sparse it's hardly anything early
anything on you know you get some people
that they don't understand boys
development we don't understand what
they're doing yet our prisons are full
of them
yet they're they're the ones that are
disrupting most of the society and yet
we we carry along with this and I think
it's because what's happened is we've
had a kind of guilt reaction in regard
to feminism and I said as I say that
because what what's actually happening
here is that there's a sort of sense
that the the that there's a that women
have been blocked but they've been
blocked by the wrong kind of it's not
that it's this not it's not these type
of men that are really doing the
blocking you know it's the right so they
so in a sense these poor boys or black
boys getting beaten up really and
they're not it's not them that's really
in in the way it's you know boy sub eats
and white boys from these are these are
the boys that are really up there doing
all all the oppressed
so the me to movement should go after
them really and in a sense what's
actually happening is working-class boys
and black boys a read at the bottom of
the rung here and and and their only way
of disrupting the society of that is is
is by being violent at the bottom so
we've got this kind of mismatch you see
and and I I'm I'm I'm all for the me to
move I think there should be a me to
movement for
black and working-class boys and white
working-class why I do think they need
and one of them one of the key elements
for them is they need we need to sort of
seriously ask about the family in the
home and not just accept this idea that
fathers are allowed to walk away or be
thrown out by whoever or the courts or
wherever and not have access to those
boys
I mean why is it important for this for
the boys to have fun because it's a back
to this sort of people like me let me
give you a me give you an example from
the that's where the Caribbean
communities are very kind of interesting
kind of development if you look at the
way girls and girls in you know doing
are doing now really well in the site
teenage pregnancy is gone virtually in
England you know it's you hardly see it
it's those numbers are gone we mean
basically we've got a society now with
the girls are doing very very well
University rates for girls are just high
nearly fifty sixty percent of the
campuses the girl will be at home on a
Sunday night seeing the legs between a
mum Kareena here and there they're
talking and they're talking their
business and they're they're having a
great time together cuz they're doing
girl stuff yeah and that she's got a
role model with her mum and her mother
is identifying figure the boy the little
boy can do some of that when he's small
when he's Tiny's but there's a point in
a boy's life and it doesn't really
matter if even if your armor sexually
there's six rallies got nothing to do
with this there's just a point in a
boy's life where he's gonna want to push
away from that mother figure and find
another another person yeah usually that
looks to be like the father hopefully to
carry out that kind of intimate work now
if the dad isn't there to do that job
he'll find it in other voice hence
that's why boys like to go around with
each other and that's what it's just
about identifying with people that look
like you and you feel an empathy with
that and I think that's that's fine the
problem is the other thing is about boys
and this is where
it's quite controversial is that
biologically we've got if you're done if
you're left standing but right handy
we've got a strong right arm and that is
that means that physically we can do a
lot of damage our ancestors realize that
that strong arm can actually tear to
pieces of village yeah so what we've got
to do it's quite interesting knife
crimes interesting there's another thing
about the right arm you know what's that
doing you know it so what that what what
the father does often and I can see in
their interactions with their sons is
that they are like the police force they
come in and they restrain those boys
yeah I always remember when you you you
look at the risk-taking that a man does
with his son you know he's very
interested going out there son
especially when they're doing riding
their bikes you know it's like I've seen
it all the time because they're
stereotyped yeah you know he fought the
boy falls off the but get up come on son
get out there you just fend off is just
a little bruised yeah get on with it you
know and I would stereotype I said the
workers around the boys it kind of just
kind of like no you know I've been oh no
and they get that they get that they get
that difference yeah that risk-taking
that you want go on boy get on with it
and actually to a certain extent the
boys like that they like that kind of
sense of but they want also as somebody
there to say know thus far and no
further
and that kind of my dad used to play my
dad used to be the sort of sign either
be in my in my home my mother used to do
when we had corporal punishment my
mother used to do all the beating in
there and she used to try our best
[Laughter]
she used to beat where were we used to
be I wish you used to give errata but
then my father was like the nuclear
weapon you know so he would be sitting
there sort of you knew that was the kind
of almost you know that is the kind of
thing that held everything that although
all the thing in plainer if you were
referred back up there that that would
be a serious and there so she said and
you could see there was like a power
going on and then and then and and I
just feel that that's with the fathers
that that figure of authority that is
missing so therefore it's not surprising
that you look at that I mean you just
see this from the amount of boys that
are on the street at night just not who
is actually telling them to come in I'm
looking about like 12 13 in fact
sometimes even younger than Wow on the
street 11:00 12:00 at night
I don't know but not you ask a policeman
when the policeman picks up that son and
this might be a massive stereotype I
know but ask any policeman you were in
there for they take that boy back home
and they've taken them back to a single
household yeah there's no man in a house
yeah so that debate we can't have in
England because somebody will turn round
to you and say what you're doing is
you're you're really beating up on the
single mother and that's become a sacred
thing now the single mother so and
they're looking at us now all these men
talking about it always the same old
thing so all against women it's all and
we're blaming them and that's that it's
not that that if you what I'm trying to
get it with you you're blaming the
father's father yeah and I'm also saying
that the father should be allowed back
here now some of them said well whoa
what what's going on here some of those
men are abusive some of them maybe but
not all of them and they need access to
it and the other thing is I think with
this is that it's actually we need to be
able to support those mothers I get
calls every week because of what I do
from single mothers saying I can't cover
this boy dr. Saul have you got any ideas
she's reached a point specially when
he's a teenager now everybody knows this
social workers lawyers politicians they
all know this but nobody wants to go
over that sacred line of saying that
look we can't do this
yeah can we have can we have some help
here you know because we're saying that
we are in the era of super women they
can do everything they can go to work
they can raise girls yeah they can also
raise boys they can do everything
so how dare you step over on that line I
think that's where we are politically
that's what we kind of amateur
discussion on it what will happen is
you'll have a discussion and the women
will turn around and say you're just
blaming us you know or it's one where
it's it's not about this is about
poverty or it's about the fact that the
boys haven't got you know sort of a
youth Youth Center to go to or things
like that which is not the real reason
why they're in this state of of
disruption they're in this rate it's a
disruption because there isn't a
restraining element at home I do you
think a lot of the gang problems and the
knife problems that we're seeing in in
London and elsewhere in the country now
is a down't of that yeah I know that
because I used to work for the Youth
Justice Board which was the the arming
in in the society that looked after
children who were in the youth offending
area now it's only about 800 kids it's
not a lot of kids you know on the on the
on the sort of real kind of serious end
of it you know and those children in
again what I did was right I kind of
went round and just asked those boys
that come on tell me what why are you
here why what was the reason for the
knife crime and two things came out of
that kind of interaction number one
there was a an admission that a point in
their lives
the father leaving or not being there is
this issue yeah and I think the other
one which was which was really
interesting about them their morality
was and this this actually was quite
pertinent for black boys was that a lot
of them pleaded not guilty for their
crime so here is a boy he's found the
knife is in the hand the police has
arrived there's they run away the knife
is in the in the head the blood
everything is all over him you're a bang
to rights yeah he reaches cool and he
pleads not guilty and and what happens
in the in our justice system
if you plead not guilty you get a longer
sentence because obviously you can't
bargain if you plead guilty then
obviously the judge would take that into
consideration so they're coughing longer
sentences
I was quite intrigued to find out why it
was that those boys were saying not
guilty because all the boys I met in all
those you threatening every one of them
was say they're not guilty what's going
on and I got it then it wasn't that it
wasn't that the police had got the facts
wrong they genuinely believed they were
not guilty because when a person
disrespected them the original offense
for the knife crime that is what they're
referring to
they're saying that that person actually
did me so wrong I was justified to kill
him so there's no that so what we've got
is you've got kids locked up in this
situation men knocked up who haven't got
any sense of the morality of what
they've done they actually still believe
no one's done any work on that they
actually believed that they were right
so they're actually literally not guilty
because they were justified to stab them
that's when they so when they plea to
the judge not guilty that's what they
said it's saying I'm not guilty
I didn't I was justified to do it that's
horrific
you know I mean so in their heads
bloody me that bit of it isn't a problem
I hate the fact that at the dance he
stepped on my shoe or dis my girlfriend
or whatever it was right that was the
the crime she is you're talking about it
now I think back to my childhood
I've been dissed in my go to your dad in
my case you know dad this is what
happened like what you know what did I
do
and he goes we'll just don't worry about
it guys a dick or whatever you know
that's what a fight sort of father
gives you a sense of where the
limitations are of your retaliation
exactly it's the mortis the moral
development what we're going down now is
the moral development of those boys the
vacuum that's there and and and and I'll
be honest the the mob was try and and
another problem with this thing about
the mothers there is a significant
amount of women who actually do really
well with their boys and take them to
the top universities and they do well
and so what happens is when you have
this conversation they roll out and they
say well what you're talking about
I had five boys and I said the otter
University super mum you know and now
but in ITER and I said well what about
that ninety percent of other women who
are not super mum who haven't got that
capacity you know what about them and I
think that's that's the problem we have
so the societies continually telling us
that women can do it all and men are
actually useless I mean that's really
the message so how do we go about
solving this i mean i mean i think i
think that the issue for me is that the
policies around certainly around some of
the settlements for boys when it comes
to who has custody in terms of the
breakup of the family we've got to
review how this thing works for boys
someone has got to kind of taught some
of those judges about that i think
there's there's an issue there in terms
of because often this happens in the
family breakup that happens the other
the other the other bit is that i just
think that we need to I think that there
should be a campaign I think the mayor's
office should be having a campaign about
the fact that you know a lot of men you
can be black or white men should be
taking responsibility of their kids and
actually making that more normal thing
what what happens sometimes in some
black Communion we've had this in the
Caribbean community that it's actually a
pride to sort of say I've dropped three
or four kids from all these different
women at a pride of my my manhood that
I've dropped all these kids and I well
I'm not taking care of them
you didn't mean and so what cuz the
state can take care of them and that's
the issue there's all the people who
then fill the prisoners exactly yeah
so what you need that you need almost
like I said a campaign to bring the
father back in a sense
not an oppressive but you know I did
that actually that it and actually make
it not a mark of good a manhood that
you've got all these kids but in fact
it's a good man is a man that takes care
of his children I'm almost like that
campaign you know in the in the heads of
our boys that that's what is it the
expectation at the moment there's just
nothing you know we don't want to go
there so I would I would love the mayor
for example to file a poster campaign of
just just suit I just remember walking
with my daughter in it would be buggy in
the hand and walking around and people
would look at me it's that kind of is
that is a strange thing to do but it's
really the natural thing to do and I'm
not that good I know mama carried her
for nine months yeah but I'm part of
that that that person so I've got be
doing my share you know I wouldn't even
think anything otherwise and it's just
like you know that kind of thing of of
what does what does a man look like you
know so man would be machine it must be
there with his and I used to be other
guys you know it was great we all be
together with our buggies you know
talking to each other and it was and it
was like in and they would say the same
thing people would say or people come
and say well done scraps that you know
well done you know you know so it's like
and all people look at it I knew the
other thing is you another interesting
issue is to do with child abuse i I
think that there's a suspicion that men
with younger children it's not natural
so it's kinda I remember when I was in I
was teaching a little boy in a nursery a
one-to-one the mother wanted me to do
sort of private lessons and and and she
was the owner of the nursery and then of
course the mothers came in you know as
if I was kind of and so there's a kind
of nervousness about men and we've made
that kind of a sort of thing about oh
you know you shouldn't be seen to you
know this thing about it distributing
for whatever it should you be seeing I
don't have anything taking pictures but
she did be swimming too close to the
children it doesn't in it subconsciously
your
kid you know yeah okay a little boy
walking right no boy just come up
through the trade I was come on
he spoke with the boy just jumped off
with me aside audibly I think you know
what's going on here you know I saw the
second take you have to take sometimes
as I'm mad when you are around yeah and
we've got this sort of thing about you
know are you the sort of you know
Sutcliffe you know are you playing and
and I just think we've got to kind of be
again that normative thing I think it's
an English thing I do think that we've
got to get back to that kind of sense
that we need we need the males back into
play yeah you know by you going you know
fathers need to take responsibility they
need to look after children there can't
be this attitude that you know you just
have all the rest of it has it has it
been supportive probably I've found it
quite even even in people I know my own
you in my own family abut we've had big
debates about this they they keep saying
to me Tony you're just over simplifying
it I hate those words over simplifying
it it's so many the problem around live
crime so complex it's poverty it's that
they didn't get a youth club they you
know it's to do with teachers it and
there's a whole range of things and so
what that when people start doing that
that long list shopping list what they
really say these back to our thing again
it's experts who don't know she said
they're just giving you this long list
because they don't because it because
that means inaction because once you
start once the list starts going too
fast five things then you're really say
into that void look we can't do anything
for you you know I mean and so what
they're saying is that you you've just
come to this problem and you're just
oversimplifying it by just saying it's
about fathers you know yet the evidence
is clear for me that disproportionately
especially if a lot of black boys are
involved in that that that's that's the
issue that they face and it's not that
it might be that knife crime isn't the
problem it might be that those boys are
just unhappy or they're in that vacuum
that moral vacuum that that means that
they then commit that crime
you know and so we've got to look at the
underlying reasons why one of the things
that for me is the key to this is the
way in which we tackled teenage
pregnancy that was a big social problem
I know about you but in London I used to
remember at the time I'm sure it's up
north as well where you'd see all these
teenage girls with these buggies walking
around this on online yeah you don't see
that anymore you don't see that anymore
not to that extent especially in London
in in in parts of Hackney we've almost
cracked that so what did they do to
develop that with two things girls got a
much more positive image about
themselves and lots more you know and
that and and and and and it also
coincided to a certain extent with some
of the positives around social media as
well so the you know it wasn't cool it's
not cool anymore to be a girl with a
buggy walking around town that just
doesn't cut it anymore and um the other
thing was they compulsive compulsive
contraceptives are not telling the
parents that works that seemed to work
as well so the injection went in and the
girls you know let's just stop them you
know and I think those two policy things
that we focused on dealt with that
problem you know it wasn't cheap we
didn't say oh it's too complicated you
know and equally I think the issue for
boys we need a similar kind of thing
around how boys are men see themselves
our fathers see themselves and making
that making it not cool to be a deadbeat
dad almost going after them really and
and then and then and then and then and
then really kind of almost in a sense
sort of saying to the boys themselves
that look here are some positive role
models and what you can be like as a as
a as a man you know and and putting that
around them so it's a counter-narrative
to the gangs
you always got to go counter to what you
know the other thing and then you'll get
a positive outcome and it's that kind of
policy thing that you need to start
engineering around those young people
and supporting those single mothers
I'm not saying to the single mothers
you've got to stay with those men but at
least do what some other women do
at least call out for help and don't say
you can do it all you know that doesn't
mean that your that doesn't put your
feminism radar lower it just means that
it just means that you're saying that
look I need some support here you know
and we should be able to support those
boys so I do think that we've done it
before and and and we can do it for
young men and tie this is one of the
areas that I really wanted to talk to
you about because it always raises its
head with the police
it's stop and search there lot of people
say that it's it's a racist policy I
stopped and searched for our global
audience is where they police stop young
men mainly young black men in searching
for knives and all the rest of it do you
agree with it do you disagree with it
where do you stand on it I mean my view
on it is quite an interesting area here
because it's like we've moved to full
circle with yourself example you'd get
you get two voices on this you get
people say I'll stop and search is bad
and it's a it's oppressive it goes in
from one community but then when there
is a knife crime the police are blamed
because they're not there in it I said
we're the police you know and usually
get that from the victims side and work
well so suddenly we've got a shift in
this and it's it's more towards saying
that okay we need we need more police
so my view on it is I think knife crime
does need quite specific policing why
just think it does it shouldn't he
doesn't need saturating policing what
you start with in the 70s 80s was a
crime would be committed did every black
man in the village in a radius of about
five miles was stopped just because you
know you you just I mean that was that
just caused mass prom I think the police
have got enough intelligence on this one
to be able to do some targeted things
where they know where those those
criminals are and where they're hanging
out and I think they should use stop and
search in that that more intelligent way
so I do think you need it but just needs
to be done better
[Music]
you know coming back to the
fatherlessness thing one of the things I
find very worrying in the piece that you
had in The Times yeah you talking about
the fact that you're trying to get this
message out there that fatherlessness is
a problem and the pushback is that a lot
of the white politicians and other
people you talk to they don't want to
raise this issue they don't want to deal
with it because of fear of being called
racist yeah right so how and and I can't
wrap my head around that that doesn't
make sense to me yeah I mean I think
that it was even worse when I used to
come out with stuff around exclusion
from schools and boys and say the black
boys and say that look this this issue
isn't necessarily about racism but it's
actually about some other things going
on in the home in the peer group and
we've got to tackle this you know and I
think equally with with with the knife
crime issue though I think I must admit
there is less of a there's less of a
sense now that people are I think the
more willingness I think to go to that
area now because of the numbers are so
clear that it is disproportionately
black boys are involved in this however
I do think that when we come to the
solutions that aiming this I mean and my
friend David Lammy is a classic example
I mean David in 2012
he was before me he said you can just go
online just tap in David Lammy knife
crime and up will come all these
articles about him saying black homes
need black fathers I mean states that
you know and and yet now it's sort of
not politically kind of so correct to do
that I hear he's roaring back a bit on
that you know he's not coming up and so
you get that sort of sense that there's
a sensitivity around this and nobody
wants to come out and state that as an
issue why and I think that I think it's
also who says it I think it's because
there is a focus on the victim what
warning is is there saying that that the
the thing that always helps us out is
the white male if we if we can find
anything to hook it on him it's a get
out of jail card for us yeah so
therefore your screen
so in this particular is that see though
it what what way way do we do you know
we can't we cannot we cannot blame the
victim here it's got to be something to
do with with with him or at least he's a
is is measures so it's to do with Tory
austerity is to do with the fact isn't a
youth club just to do with the police
you know and the way they see themselves
it's to do with with with white teachers
excluding them from schools anything and
everything but not the home I think
that's the progress so that's really
worry so but once you start going back
into the home you don't you talk about
agency then you talking about
responsibilities of those those
communities and that's that's the
difference you see there nobody wants to
take that especially if you're a
politician who's who's been kind of
almost put up on on the basis that I am
here to protect you from that horrible
world the walls out there that are
coming to get you
so therefore my narrative has always got
to come back to the fact that you're
oppressed not for the fact that the
oppression might be something to do with
what's going on in your home yeah and or
another type of oppression that you
might be perpetuating yourself no you
can't go there and that's where we
that's that's where we've become stuck
but what I think this this issue has
come up is that it as I said I think
that particularly black boys it there a
problem for that kind of rhetoric they
confound that because they as those boys
say look the biggest issue for me was
the fact that my old man left or he
wasn't there or downstairs I was busy
kind of refitting an airgun so that it
could be used as a God while my daughter
was upstairs doing well my sister was
upstairs doing her work and my dad or
the dads of the three of us the three
different dads just were not here that's
the reality that that I face you know
and so to me that's that's that's where
it it lies and so it's difficult for
munities to come back and say well we've
got to try and sort this out ourselves
you see what I don't understand there's
a guy in America Larry old I don't know
if you him right and Larry he has some
interesting points along the same lines
that you make but he's a guy he just
talks right he's a radio host he's very
articulate very good but he talks right
but you've proven it through the work
that you do and still people are afraid
to say there should be hundreds of
generating geniuses around the country I
think that it yeah there should be and I
think that people are waking up to it
but I think that it's it's a harder one
I mean what's also happened is that the
pot and here's another thing about
generating genus it makes it a little
bit different and people kind of don't
get it a bit is that what it's trying to
do is saturate the mindset of that
community
with young people that are doing very
well it's a kind of it's almost like a
kind of counterintuitive thing because
what you usually do in policies is you
go you said to say we're gonna stack all
our resources on on the very few kids
that are causing all this disruption now
admittedly day I mean when they kill
somebody that's a massive disruption so
you've got to do something but what what
we're saying is that actually what you
need to do is you need to you need to
change a narrative around that group
that's what we like what we did with the
teenage girls and so therefore you you
actually may be needing to sort of go
after as I say children are who are and
making sure that there is that there is
a story for them what's quite
interesting is that the kids are my
program come from the same schools that
the kids who commit knife crime come
from they come from the same schools so
it's not like they're going off to eat
no Harris or no the same estates the
same schools yet they're ending up at
the top universities so that that is
powerful
you should I mean because you're saying
well they save money the same is the
same lack of youth clubs or ever
austerity that same and to a certain
extent same lack of fathers and that's
quite interesting as well you know in
their in their homes and yet one group
is doing well another is and the other
one that confirms it all is girls I
moment the group that is doing best in
London are girls from a West African
background and they're doing really well
in school so what you've got in some
homes you've got the girl upstairs busy
doing our work going off to top
university and a boy downstairs getting
ready for prison and that is happening
in a lot of black homes two pathways for
the same kid in the same household and
so that's that's what you what you're
saying is absolutely right in fact what
you need then is is is it something
that's going to tackle the real core
problem
yeah not pussyfoot around it which is
really what's what's been happening in
the past and it's because we're not
allowing ourselves and this is probably
I've never had this is the most honest
and open conversation I've ever had with
any media on this issue and I've never
heard people talk about it openly
because it's always this Oh what should
I say the right thing you know all that
and so we never get to it it's amazing
what you say I mean what part of this I
mean this is it that they is is white
guilt where people especially like you
know like what being a white man you've
just got I want to ask this question but
is it races if I ask this question am I
making you know just a general
assumption about black people black men
in general am i doing my friend am I
gonna get upset and there's also selfish
part of you want all self-preservation
element where you go well I don't want
to address that because it's just too
difficult and too challenging a subject
yeah and I think that bit about it being
too difficult and challenging the
subject is the one that to me gets in
the way but yeah you're right there's a
lot of guilt running around this thing
is that that's really interesting and
gilts in a way is is difficult I'm
having I'm having difficulties with even
films and and stories that keep running
the guilt story you know it to the point
where because I think that you the
narrative that says oh you know all
these people did this to me is is
interesting and I think to remind people
I started off but
you a story of that in that room with
their journalist you know so I'm not
unaware of the the kind of difficulties
that people have in terms of relating to
other groups and women should know that
this is frustrating for me is that where
we're right where I see women not not
kind of standing together with me on
this is that they almost can I see their
of their kind of thing is very similar
to black boys you know and we talked
about this in a sense of obsession with
the body the whole thing about
surveillance or whatever lack of
opportunities all these things and then
agency the the ability to sort of see
opportunities and Caeser and go for it
yourself they have similar problems then
yeah they don't then have anything then
I have they have very little empathy
with that because what happens is they
just still go for the default position
that are well you know in the end these
are boys and you feel they don't even
like boys and I get I get I get a sense
that that's almost what's going on here
that our society our society doesn't
like little boys I mean it kind of
there's a kind of sense that they're
getting the way you know remember if
you're a boy you're gonna have you're
likely to have mom at home her friends
then you go into school you can have a
female teacher you know the whole in
fact you heart you you hardly see a man
I would give you a something that's
really interesting you can go to someone
some primary schools now and I just
happened to me a number of occasions you
go into the primary school and suddenly
all these little boys start writing up
writing up towards you it's it's quite
it's quite scary almost like you're
Santa Claus you go yes yeah if they
think that they secretly think you're
gonna be their teacher that's it but
they talking to you they cut it cut
because if you sit down with some of
those but they actually do not have any
interaction with any armed male adult
Authority none
crazy well Tony it's like you said
yourself it's been a very honest and a
very very young chat we really thank you
for coming on for the work you're doing
like I said I hope that as part of this
conversation and other media to easily
do there are a hundred generating
geniuses around the country eventually
thanks for having me
it's one which is what is the thing that
people aren't talking about but really
should be it well I think we've chosen
one of these it's got to be that the
issue about fathers of men really in the
society we've got winning then we've got
to have a proper grown-up debate about
about that and and and come to terms
with that and I think that just just
debating honestly what would take us
further ok well that's been absolutely
wonderful think you so much for you man
Tony as always follow us at trigger pod
and all the social media we're on PayPal
if you enjoy the show and want to keep
supporting it as you have been many of
you patreon as well for now and thank
you very much we we will see you in the
weeks time from now with another
brilliant episode absolutely like and
subscribe on our youtube channel click
the bell icon which will tell you every
time one of our videos is released and
if also as well you could rate us in
itunes we'd be really grateful and if
you like us and you know you were bit
embarrassed like there's no no one is
true because well because you think you
know where you're worried about being
judged because you're a nazi or whatever
else and just tell somebody in secret
about people listening spread the word
but guys thank you so much and we'll see
you next week you know it's
[Music]
you